hi
this is the less dominant side of this
form so we begin in the shogunate
position i immediately can tell that i'm
not able to make him go anywhere he's
too stable i checked the elbow and
moving in behind him so this is the odor
was apart i'm moving to his rear side
as i do this i'm going to grab his wrist
and pull his body tight to me grabbing
his hand and his fingers now ideally
here i'd be able to control him from the
sankyo but this is the guy who's going
to be too strong for me he continues in
to come towards me like he's going to
tackle my legs here so he doesn't care
that i have the sunkeep but as he comes
into tech on my leg i draw his arm out
and step behind he falls into a little
hole where he thought i was going to be
as he comes down here i drop the inside
knee here and i have a lot of torque on
this shoulder and wrist the free hand
comes over and grabs i lock this to my
chest and turn my body twerking both the
wrist and the shoulder one more time at
speed
thank you